[Musique]
difficile d'imaginer dans cette nature
luxuriante qu'au delà d'un petit pont de
bois protégés par les charmes et s'étend
sur trois hectares un verger pas comme
les autres
la pommeraie idéal est avant tout une
rencontre avec son amante
voilà sept jardins sur les trois
hectares sept jardins différents mais
qui montrent tous des pommiers pour la
plupart qui sont tous formés sur des
structures métalliques qui ont pour
particularité de demander beaucoup de
temps à être formé un petit peu
l'originalité de ce projet infographiste
de formation jardinier de coeur et de
profession dominique still has est loin
d'être banale à chaque visite
il explique ainsi ce qui l'a conduit à
mener son projet et à s'intéresser au
pommier première étape historique sont
donc 21 ans et malus sylvestris c'est à
dire le premier des forêts
c'est un arbre qui est implantée en
europe depuis extrêmement longtemps
c'était le premier la première pomme
qu'ont pu déguster si je puis dire nos
ancêtres il ya vingt mille ans déjà
laissons de côté le clos des rainettes
pour pénétrer tout de suite au coeur de
l'oeuvre du jardinier ici nous sommes
dans le clos des bayles se clôt damon
c'est ça alors qu'est ce que c'est c'est
très surprenant toutes ses formes
particulière des ce palier et on peut
dire que ce sont quand même des classes
et des formes en volume qui sont
apparues au 19e siècle
après tout un travail d'amélioration ça
commençait à la renaissance comme
souvent dans les cours des châteaux les
guerres du moyen-âge étant finie on fait
des châteaux de plaisance c'est les
châteaux de la loire en italie à la même
émulation à culturel et artistique et il
ya des grandes cours de châteaux dans
lesquels on va commencer à orner pallice
et des arbres fruitiers contre ces murs
qu'il faut orné et on va faire les
premiers essais de porte-greffes les
premiers essais de palissage tout cela
au fil des siècles va se perfectionner
pour arriver à la fin du 19e siècle à
des choses très compliquées
c'est au potager du roi au château de
versailles que ces techniques ont séduit
le jardinier au point d'en faire une
véritable passion depuis déjà une
dizaine d'années mais sculpter des
arbres fruitiers est un travail de
longue haleine
c'est pas très compliqué c'est pas de la
biologie moléculaire mais il faut être
là constamment c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on fait comme ça en dilettante
c'est beaucoup de patience il faut être
là constamment faut pas rater certaines
étapes même contrainte pour le jardin
clos suivant temps et patience pour
aboutir au résultat final là on arrive
dans le cloître
alors le cloître c'est une pergola qui
reproduit larchitecture d'un cloître
j'étais dans les cloîtres pour voir
comment était fait les ogives les
croisées d'ogives ces magnifiques ainsi
ré agencer toujours de la même façon il
ya une structure métallique qui est
planté et à la base de chaque montants
métalliques un pommier est planté et le
but c'est d'avoir des fleurs des
guirlandes de fleurs et des guirlandes
de fruits sous les ogives et sous les
croisées d'ogives donc ça c'est encore
un chantier dans le chantier c'est à une
distance de 5 à 10 ans
à terme ce lieu servira de salle de
spectacle à ciel ouvert quand on sait
que les sculptures entreprises ne seront
pour certaines fini qu'en 2050
on comprend mieux que ce qui guide
dominique est très singulier ce qui
m'intéressait de tenter des choses qui
n'ont jamais été
tentez donc là je suis à cheval sur pas
mal de choses originales comme je disais
estime qu'avec de la chose artistique
avec de la chose historique également ce
sont des s'agit pas de remettre tout ça
au goût du jour mais de montrer que ça
existait parce que ça fait partie de
notre patrimoine
une heure de visite parfois techniques
parfois historiques toujours passionnant
on ressort de la pommeraie avec une
autre vision du temps et la furieuse
envie d'être encore là pour déambuler
sous les pommiers en fleurs du poids et
c'est ainsi que s'achève cette édition
merci de votre fidélité
le 19/20 continue avec le journal de la
rédaction nationale bonne soirée à
demain
[Musique]
mamadou